Michael Brown was particularly
interesting because there's a young man
with we had a promising future in fact
that they left his body on the streets
while I was saying this person is not
human through our practices through our
culture and certain who are policing we
send a message every day that black
lives don't matter
we've constituted whiteness in this
country is an opposition to blackness so
what we call a good neighborhood is
where there very few black people what
we've done is we institutionalize fear
of the of the racial other and then we
actually organize society around them
always to protect against white fear and
there's no end to white fear the role of
the police is to contain the black
community to keep white people safe from
the black community the first reaction
when you talk about this is always I'm
not a racist
you know I maybe have black friends I
and when a person says that Rather's the
police or someone from society at large
they may be telling the truth they may
not be but they may be telling the truth
but they don't consciously Harbor racial
bias then it doesn't mean that the
unconscious is not harboring racial
biases black people themselves will have
negative implicit biases toward black
people we see 5,000 images available
and those images are get lodged into the
unconscious mind and many people's
images of blacks are negative but it's
not enough to have a conversation
because the problem is profoundly
cultural and structural we have to
really look at the relationship between
the police and black America and the
rest of America like the kind of
training I would suggest is you have to
go do community service in the community
before you become a police get to know
the children in the school go play
basketball with the young black boys in
high school and junior high school not
so much so they get to know you so you
get to know them there's a song that the
history banana says can be written along
who is a citizen and when people talk
about taking the country back and
talking about taking it back from the
elites from corporate America they're
talking about taking it back from blacks
from immigrants and the notion that this
is a white country we have to get beyond
that but I always emphasize that we're
not simply trying to get rid of biases
you're never gonna give it a ball biases
we're not trying to make people simply
think that our thoughts were trying to
change practices we're trying to
actually create a society where black
lives in fact do matter
you